and then you know there's nothing good
there's nothing bad that nothing right
nothing wrong to be done in this game
but it's it's your story
hello my name is Guillaume the phone and
Quantic Dream's co-ceo and the executive
producer of Detroit become human
[Music]
the carrot character touches my
emotional fiber this journey for love is
I think very very interesting on the
other hand you know with Marcus we're
touching upon a topic that's also
extremely interesting you know how far
will you go to be free and how much can
you fight for your beliefs and
color it's an interesting
character it's about loyalty
your train program educated to do
certain things what if one moment
something happens to you and you're
shattered your beliefs what do you
what is interesting about the games I
don't have to choose I can play
and so they see this story from these
very different perspectives not only
because there are three different models
but also because we were touching a
problem very
different
problem ethics it's been a huge
challenge to create this game to take
Lydia on David because you know you have
to imagine there is one writer who's
writing the story and
craft is going to feed the entire studio
of course we've been influenced by the
initial Blade Runner it's always been an
interesting topic I guess it's because
humanity knows that this evolution or
revolution is coming with senses maybe
all of the technology that we've
developed in the past
120 years is going to come in it we're
probably going to start creating
machines at our image and we're sensing
that they will have maybe the
possibility of becoming as intelligent
if they're more intelligent than us when
interested us most is that it's a topic
where a lot of choices involved and when
you're confronted with the stories gives
you the possibility to make critical
decisions for yourself but with also
impact on society and maybe humanity at
large so it was a perfect context to a
certain degree to create an interactive
drama creating this game we've gone
through a lot of emotions the excitement
of starting a new project the fear the
sheer fear not being able to accomplish
it that always happens in a project in a
project that massive
we had a number of moments where we
thought oh my God why are we doing this
why did we decide to create so many
branches to push PlayStation 4 tease out
the limits in certain areas and graphics
etc etc right now I'm excited for the
release and for players to finally get
their hands on it because that's
ultimately what we are about we're about
creating experiences that players were
taking the house so today color markers
in Kara no longer are characters
become players characters and all the
board your decisions are going to make a
story it's a mixture between relief and
pride relief to have accomplished and
very proud because we've set up at the
start of this journey we set that with
with very ambitions and I think where we
deliver it here with Detroit and all the
very strong promises were made to
ourselves to create not only our most
ambitious but also our most branching
story
exploration is is a very important
component in all games not only when you
play as Connor and to investigate
Franklin's which to a certain degree
implies that you need to be curious but
with all three characters in fact I
think there's a lot to explore we've put
a lot of small scenarios here and there
with Marcus for instance and you go to
city of Detroit you'll have two
possibility to take your GPS and go in a
straight line but you also have the
possibility to go you know left and
right and explore then you're going to
need other characters you wait to see
certain things and this is why it's
difficult so to answer the question how
long does it take to finish the game
we've really seen in user tests a
certain players can be finished in one
playthrough in 10 to 12 hours others in
20 hours there are more than 300
characters of this game that you're
going to interact with some will become
your friends somewhere become your films
some will accompany you through your
journey from the starts the beginning
other or simply not survive or take
another pass on their own so it makes
for a very huge area of possibilities
for a player
what makes this experience so unique
Detroit a certainty our most ambitious
game not only from a technological
graphic or animation standpoint and
everything but also because we wanted to
take to touch upon certain themes
certain topics that are socially
relevant for each of us and of course
that comes with a challenge because you
know you need to go about these things
with the right sensitivity you need to
be mindful of feelings of the people but
on the other hand I think it's here
again something very interesting because
you put players in front of very
emotional contexts and you ask
themselves questions but we're not
coming with a message to humanity our
purpose as creators is to ask questions
and give players the possibility to
answer these questions to put their own
values in weight and to motivate these
choices sometimes you're confronted with
you talked about domestic abuse very
good example you know hope most players
are going to fight against it of course
but in other instances there are
questions that are not white or black
and it's not the balance making a choice
that everyone would do so there's going
to be a lot of hesitation I think we're
trying to create an emotional reaction
from players we'd like to do it with
sensibility with feelings and always
within a meaningful story but I invite
players to play the game in to confirm
themselves these questions there's
nothing good there's nothing bad that
nothing right but nothing wrong to be
done in this game
but it's it's your story
[Music]